-Today's Friday and that's
usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and, of course,
send out thank you notes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I was just
running a bit behind.
I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank you notes
right now.
Is that cool?
[ Cheering and applause ]
James, can I get some thank yo
note writing music, please
[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Wow.
Olympic spirit.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Thank you, Olympics,
for, once again,
making me jealous
that there are people
who get paid
to jump on trampolines.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Olympic diving,
for not going
by your original name --
impressive falling.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Aaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
-Beep, beep, beep.
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you, athlete bedrooms
in the Olympic Village,
for finally answering
the question,
"Can dorm rooms get
even more depressing?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-"Here's where you're staying.
-Oh, my God.
-No crowds.
Stay right here."
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you,
Milwaukee Bucks logo,
for looking more like
the logo you'd find
on a pair of camo sandals
at Bass Pro Shops.
[Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
They have like the bottle
opener on the bottom.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Thank you, summer weddings
for giving me
the exciting opportunity
to sweat through the
nicest clothes I own.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, pill bottles,
or, as I like to call you,
medicine maracas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Medicine maracas.
[ Maracas rattling ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
mosquito-repellant bracelets
You may not actually work,
but, hey, at least I look
like I'm wearing a phone cor
from the '80s.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Do they still have
those phone cords
you used to attach to kids
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
That was crazy.
-That was a mistake, right
-Big mistake.
I don't want to watch them
I just want them on a leash.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I love it when it's jus
completely stretched out.
Like, "My kid's
in the next door."
Yeah.
-"If it goes slack, tell me.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Thank you, picnic tables,
for finding a way
to make sitting down feel like
climbing into a window.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Thank you, portable neck fans,
or, as I like to call you,
Breeze by Dre.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, everybody
Those are our thank you notes.